[Music]
hello and welcome to i'd like to know
for those of you who have been watching
for a while this is our
bible question and answer program well
we take your questions we go to the word
of god and we try to mine the word of
god for answers that are we pray meet in
due season for our souls and for your
souls as well i'm in the company of our
speaker director pastor stephen bohr
pastor always good to study the word of
god with you amen feeling is mutual
and we praise the lord i say study the
word of god because we study
independently and then we allow the holy
spirit to bring our minds and our hearts
together and that's part of the fun of
this program that uh we get to study and
come together and answer your questions
should you like to participate and many
of you have the pastor tells me he has
on his desk a fairly impressive pile of
papers that we need to get to and that
we'll try to get to uh through each
program but should you like to
participate and
have your question answered or at least
wrestled with by
either either he or i
you can write to tv
at some tv.org that's tv
at some tv dot o rg you see it there on
the bottom of the screen we will take
them and get to them just as soon as we
can
uh and do the best we can to give you an
answer from the word of god i'm going to
ask my dear pastor and friend to
lead us in prayer and then we'll launch
out into today's program and today's
questions
let's pray
father in heaven we come before your
awesome throne
knowing that you know everything
and our knowledge is so limited
however we thank you for your word
because your word has all of the answers
to the crucial questions that we need to
understand at this time amen
so we ask for the presence of the spirit
as we open your word and attempt to
answer these questions
we ask lord that those who are viewing
will be blessed
as well as us
so we place ourselves in your hands
asking that you will do your will
we pray this in the precious name of
jesus
amen amen and amen
all right pastor i'm going to read this
question and um
toss it out there and maybe you can take
the lead on this
this is coming from dave
i'm confused
about something that i hope you can
clarify was of the understanding that
the official policy of the seventh
adventist church was not to allow women
to be pastors or elders of the churches
now i am told that it is okay
with the
adventist church if local churches have
pastors or elders of their local church
isn't that a little like states not
having to obey federal laws
shouldn't local churches obey the
official policy of the worldwide
seventh-day adventist church please
explain
well you know
the final authority on these issues
is not the world church
the final
word on this issue is the word of god
what does the word of god teach
now
there have been cases in the history of
the church
where the church has gotten it wrong
because you know if we believe that the
church gets everything right
then we're not any better than roman
catholics because we're believing that
the declarations of the church are
infallible
so
this issue of women elders and women
pastors needs to be resolved from the
perspective of the bible
and the spirit of prophecy not from the
perspective of
what scholars say
or even what the church says yes
now i respect the authority of the
church
but the bible trumps the authority of
the church as far as i'm concerned
pastor before you go on
take just a moment you bring a unique
perspective to this now i've been at
every general conference since 1985 and
i've i've been on the general conference
committee and i've heard this issue
fleshed out and dealt with but you
actually sat on one of the committees
that was structured by the general
conference to address this just
just tap the break and just talk about
that a little bit because you do bring a
unique perspective uh you've been
wrestling with this and i use that term
for quite a while
from from an official capacity
of the seventh-day adventist church
well yeah i belong to the uh theology of
our ordination study committee of the
general conference we had four meetings
leading up to the san antonio general
conference in 2015
and the issue was discussed there and
there was division in the camp there
were those who were in favor of
ordaining women as pastors and there
were those who were against ordaining
women as pastors but there's a deeper
issue than ordaining pastors who are
female
the issue is the ordination of elders
yes does the bible authorize the
ordination of women elders
and the answer to that question is no
and unfortunately the church
actually the annual council
of the church which is the executive
committee of the general conference
authorized the ordination of women
elders
and the problem with that is that
an elder
and a pastor in the bible are
indistinguishable
the same qualifications for one are for
the other
uh only that the local elder uh
can serve only in that local church
correct whereas the elder the pastor who
is ordained as an elder can serve the
world church of the world basically the
job description is the same
uh for both uh for both of those
positions
so basically this was the argument of
many of us on the theology of ordination
study committee
that the bible does not authorize what
the annual council authorized which is
the ordination of women elders the issue
the big issue is not whether we ordain
women as pastors the issue is whether we
ordain them as elders because if they're
ordained as elders that's the same
ordination as pastors yes basically
and so
my view is that their the church
needs to
backtrack
and needs to rescind the authorization
toward name or ordain women elders and i
know that that's not popular it it has
gained me a lot of enemies
both
inside and outside the church
but that is the real issue
does the bible authorize the ordination
of women elders and of course the answer
to that question is no
the bible makes the qualifications of
the elder or the bishop
which are interchangeable
an issue where the individual has to be
of the male gender
maybe we can read some passages from
scripture
um
we can go to
titus chapter 1
and verses 5 through 9 and most of the
arguments are you know uh culture well
you know the culture today kind of
requires that and you know there's a lot
of arguments that are not based on
scripture
um titus chapter 1 and if you want to
read verses 5 through 9. i will do so
titus chapter 1 verse 5 i'm reading from
the new king james for this reason i
left you in crete that you should set in
order the things that are lacking and
appoint elders in every city as i
commanded you
if a man is blameless the husband of one
wife having faithful children not
accused of dissipation and
insubordination for a bishop must be
blameless as a steward of god
not self-willed not quick-tempered not
given to wine not violent not greedy for
money
but hospitable a lover of what is good
sober-minded just holy self-controlled
holding fast the faithful word as he has
been taught that he may be able by sound
doctrine both to exhort and convict
those who contradict
so the key part of this passage is
that an elder must be
the husband of one wife
[Music]
so in other words the elder has to be a
male yes the husband of one wife
now let's go for also to first timothy
first timothy chapter 3 and verses 1
through verse
7.
you want to read that
first timothy 3 1-7
all righty first timothy 3
this is a faithful saying
if a man desires the position of a
bishop
he desires a good work a bishop must be
blameless the husband of one wife
temperate sober-minded of good behavior
hospitable able to teach
not given to wine not violent not greedy
for money but gentle
not quarrelson not covetous one who
rules his own house well having his
children in submission with all
reverence for if a man does not know how
to rule his own house
how will he take care of the church of
god
not a novice lest being puffed up with
pride he fall into the same condemnation
as the devil and verse seven moreover
he must have a good testimony among
those who are outside lest he fall into
reproach
and the snare of the devil now two key
parts uh two key ideas in this passage
first of all once again it says that the
that the bishop the word bishop is
episcopal which means overseer somebody
who oversees or supervises
the overseer once again it says must be
the husband of one wife
and then in verse five
people say okay
i'm willing to accept that in the home
the husband the the you know the husband
should be the head of the household
but uh that doesn't mean that the
overseer of the church needs to be of
the male gender
verse 5 contradicts that idea because
verse 5 says for if a man does not know
how to rule his own house
how will he take care of the church of
god
so so ruling in the house
and ruling in the church is a
qualification for ruling
in the church yes and it must be the
husband of one wife
when you read the bible as it's written
but unfortunately culture
has one has wanted to infiltrate the
church and decisions are made on the
basis of culture
instead of being made on the basis of
what the word of god says
now let's go to first corinthians
chapter 11.
first corinthians chapter 11.
by the way i have a group of study notes
that i did on this
uh it's about 200 plus pages the title
is in the beginning
where i deal with all of these matters
there's so much that could be said about
this
but in first corinthians chapter 11 and
verse 3 god gives us
god gives us the order
that he established
it says but i want you to know that the
head of every man is christ
the head of the woman is man
and the head of christ is god
now
those who favor women's ordination they
like two of the phrases of verse three
i want you to know that the head of the
of every man is christ they're fine with
that
and they're fine with uh the last part
and the head of christ is god yes but
when it comes to
the head of the woman is the man
they say no no no that doesn't apply
but actually what you have is an order
of functioning here
a leadership order the head of christ is
god the father
christ is the head of the man and the
man is the head of the woman
does that mean that the woman is
inferior of course not is christ
inferior because the father is his head
no no no is uh is the woman inferior
because the man is the head of the woman
absolutely not no
the the argument that if you don't
believe that women should be ordained as
elders and pastors then you believe that
women are inferior is a false argument
because what you're dealing with is with
a difference of function
you're not dealing with ontological
equality
as persons
men and women are equal
but they're not equal in function
in the home or in the church
and so basically
um
you know the we need to go back to what
the bible teaches about this not let
culture dictate what we do but let the
scriptures
tell us what we're supposed to do when
it comes to church leadership yes this
is very very important because the
church is still wrestling with this it
is has not been settled in a way that
has pleased all people maybe it never
will
having so said um
you know it it's i think your point in
the very beginning that it's it's more
than the church it's the word of god
we are answerable to the church uh we
get our paycheck from the church those
of us who are who are on church payroll
but uh all of us must give an answer to
god
every man every woman every boy every
girl
and and our marching orders come
through the church but they come from
god
and so our reckoning must be with god
now there are some people who don't like
that there are some people who are out
of harmony with the will of god that it
must be stated as such um but ultimately
they're going to not now
his question says well it's like it's
like
obeying federal law
well
there are some who are out of harmony
with the church the church has allowed
and it was sort of an interim step i
think to calm the the nervous hearts and
the loud voices okay well we let him
have of uh uh the local elder but as you
have well
said it's the same the only difference
is the ordained pastor is ordained to
the world church the local elders
functions are limited to the local
church but they are the same
and once you do one you have
de facto done the other
you know if people are really interested
in pursuing this after the san antonio
general conference session in 2015
i wrote a very lengthy article
for our newsletter
titled reflections on san antonio
and i i show all of the trajectory of
the women's ordination debate debate in
the seventh-day adventist church
and if anyone who is uh watching this
program would like to get a copy
of that newsletter article which gives
the entire process that has been
followed in the history of the adventist
church concerning women's ordination
they can actually order a copy from
secrets unsealed
so the title of it is reflections on san
antonio and i think it would be a real
blessing to to see
the process that was followed in saying
yes we can ordain women as elders but we
can't
ordain them as pastors that's
theological schizophrenia yes because
because
it's discriminatory
on what biblical basis can you say women
can be ordained as elders but women can
be can't be ordained faster the line is
artificial you've drawn an artificial
line yeah absolutely and it's actually
that is discrimination against women
saying that they cannot be uh ordained
as pastors but they can be ordained as
elders yes it would be better to follow
the biblical standard and say let men
fulfill their role and let women fulfill
their role that god has established
and if that was done
it would actually resolve the problem
that we're presently in in the adventist
church yes we've nipped and talked a
little bit there was a vote taken in in
san antonio into 2015
that
entities divisions
unions conferences were not allowed to
dare i say do their own thing
but that didn't deal with the heart of
the issue right
it it tried to keep the world field in
line on the same page as it were but it
didn't really deal with the question and
until that question is dealt with once
and for all it will come back again and
again and again and again it may have
different clothes on each time it comes
but it's the same mannequin just dressed
a little differently and there's a very
interesting detail
you know usually the annual council
right before the next general conference
session
sets the agenda
for the general conference session yes
it was authorized to ordain
women elders by the spring meeting which
is the spring meeting of the general
conference executive committee in 1975
and that was in north america yes and
then in 1984
it that was authorized to
ordain women elders
the world field with many many uh
mitigating factors which have not been
followed by the way yes
and and so the the i the ideal thing
would have been
to after that discussion of women's
ordination when it was approved for the
world field in 1984 well the general
conference session was the next year in
1985.
why wasn't the ordination of women
elders taken to the 1985 general
conference session
why wasn't it taken to the 1990 session
why was it taken to the 1995 session yes
why was it taken to the 2000 session
2005 session 2010 session 2015 session
yes the reason why is because they knew
it wasn't going to pass right the world
field would not vote in favor of it very
true so this is the point the executive
committee of the general conference
approved women's ordination but the
world church never did
ordination as elders the world church
never did interesting so why not take it
to the world church and let the world
church decide if we should ordain women
elders or not ordained women elders the
reason why it hasn't been taken such an
important issue as this is because those
who are in favor of ordaining women
elders which are mainly in the so-called
developed world know
that they would that they would lose the
vote precisely and uh that should not be
the motivation for us doing things in
the church we should do things because
the bible tells us that we should do
them or we should not do them very true
very true very true this is a
a um an issue that has drawn over the
last 20
25 years much heat
sometimes not always much light but
certainly much heat but um so much of
this dust could be settled if we just
went with the word of god we didn't
culturally impose anything on the word
of god we we dealt with the word of god
as stated by the word of god it would
make things so much simpler it sure
would yes
we long for that day
and by the way this is not disloyalty to
the church
uh you know we believe that this is
god's remnant church
uh we believe that this is a church that
has the truth of god
it has present truth for this time oh
yes but the church does make mistakes
the church is not infallible because if
the church was infallible
then we would have to we'd have to be
roman catholics
because they believed that you know the
dogmas of the roman catholic church are
irreformable and unchangeable yes we
don't believe that in the adventist
church
and if we did it would be a papal system
that's a good point
to sort of put it that way we we would
have to be uh catholic in our thinking
because
you can't question when the church is
always right well sometimes the church
doesn't make mistakes yes and that's why
they put erasers on the end of pencils
right and uh
that's you know we are the church
militant
not the church triumphant there we go
right yet praise the lord okay we have
another question uh the the next one is
uh i think we're able to cover it in the
time that we have ca
um let's see um
tithe
yes okay maybe this is obvious but i'm
sure others have this question should
people return tithe on money from aid
such as financial aid from school
disability or unemployment benefits i've
heard you shouldn't return tithe on
money from loans since it's money that
you're going to pay back and not income
and that makes sense to me
okay now that's a that's a con complex
question isn't it indeed it is
well what does the bible say that's the
big question
i um
the bible tells us to pay tithe on your
increase
um to me
when the bible tells me that i tithe my
increase
when i
well first thing i i pay tithe on my
gross and not my net i look at my check
as it usually comes from my employer and
that first figure before any deductions
are made including
uncle sam including the government state
and federal i pay tithe on that total
amount
um
i want god to bless me on the gross so i
pay on the gross not on the net i don't
want net blessings i want gross
blessings amen amen
you know it's interesting
um while i was working you know our
classification was self-employed yes
even though we're employed by the
conference kind of kind of an oxymoron
type thing
but
you know i would receive in my check
the total amount of my salary
plus benefits
and they they did not withhold
social security
you know you had to make quarterly
payments from the money that you got in
your checks yes
and so we would make quarterly uh
quarterly payments of course we because
of all the clergy benefits i never had
to pay much federal tax but social
security was a significant amount yes
now
what should i have done
should have should i have said
well this much for social security i'm
not benefiting from social security yet
until i retire
so i'm going to discount that from what
i'm going to tithe yes
i never did that
i simply like you
tie the gross
in other words
even
even at the end of the year
though i could have discounted
the social security because i wasn't
benefiting until retirement true i said
you can't out give the lord
and so i
tie the gross
and then i retired
and the money that the the government
sends me for retirement i tied that too
no i probably wouldn't have to
yeah because because i already tithed it
up to a certain amount
but i'm not going to sit down and i'm
going to say you know
to the last penny how much do i owe the
lord you can't out give the lord
precisely our his blessings are so great
that if i'm paying a double tithe so be
it praise the lord praise the lord
praise the lord yeah um and and it
someone said to me years ago you know
when when you pay your tithe you're
saying lord i have enough
i have enough to do what i need to do
you're you're believing you're trusting
and it's all a matter of faith i've i've
had people come to me and and and bring
me their bills you know and say i can't
pay tithe here's what i make here's what
i spend
you know if i paid tithe i'd go in a
hole i cannot afford to pay tithe uh
i've had that happen to be at least on
two occasions and i remember one
very very well she was very upset single
mother with a growing son she said i
can't i can't i can't do it i i said you
can't afford not to because if if your
son catches a cold if he coughs you're
you're bankrupt you're in the hole you
need the good will of the lord you more
than anybody need to pay your tithe yeah
and trust god amen you know what i tell
people that say
pastor i don't have enough money to pay
my bills and to return the tithe i it
just simply doesn't work i say to them i
have a formula where you always have
enough to pay tithe pay it first
but the problem is if i pay it first i'm
not going to be able to pay my bills so
in other words
you are are more faithful
in paying
paying your bills yes then you are in
pain in returning the tithe of the lord
and and then i tell them stories of
people who
didn't have enough money
in their mind to return the tithe and
they decided to return to the tithe god
always comes through yes god always
makes it possible now
some people are simply sloppy in their
finances and they overspend and then
they say well i don't have enough money
to tithe yeah but if you're responsible
in your in handling your um financial
matters
and you tithe first
god is always going to provide what you
mean and he says in malachi prove me
test me try me
let's let's see and if if if i fail you
well then you get to shake your finger
in my face but i won't fail you because
i never have and the cattle on a
thousand hills the gold and silver it's
mine i can give you what you need i can
give you your portion but you've got to
exercise the faith to put me first yeah
and i will show you that i am faithful
and that has been my own personal
experience
you know
what i'm sharing is not simply you know
the bible says this i have actually done
it yes always paid a return to faithful
tithe
and sometimes we've been tight
financially
but we've never lacked never lack food
never lack clothing
never lack shelter amen we were never
sued for for unpaid bills god always
provided amen well very engaging
discussion indeed um it's just about
time to end uh we want to thank you for
sending all of your questions to us
please remember to send them tv at
sumtv.org
god bless you hope to see you next time
on this program i'd like to know
[Music]
you